nobody crazy that that mention is is
would not be in this mood you mention s
I said Michael Douglas I'm like is my
gun other than a moment poor a teen one
singing frozen I mean I'm just saying
yes in the movie
how's it going everybody there's a lot
of hype right now regarding this
interviewed that Sebastian Stan is in
where he apparently gave away a big
spoiler about Avengers four as you saw
in the interview he said that Michael
Douglas is going to be in Avengers four
which is very interesting because as of
right now Michael Douglas's character
dr. Henry Hank Pym is dust so a lot of
people are asking what this means
wondering if he's just going to make a
little cameo in the end of the movie
where him and all the other fallen
heroes come back or if he's going to
play some sort of bigger role in
Avengers 4 so I'll talk about a few
possibilities of how it could play out
in Avengers 4 with dr. Pym I'm still
giving away copies of Infinity Ward
Deadpool 2 and Ant Man and the wasp on
blu-ray as well as some special edition
posters if you would like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
okay so let's start with the obvious we
all know that the people who fell victim
to Thanos as snap are going to be
brought back somehow
we know the guardians of the galaxy are
coming back thanks to Dave Bautista we
know that spider-man far from home is
shooting and wrapping up right now we
know that Doctor Strange too could begin
filming at any moment there have been
several leaks and spoilers that tell us
that the people who were victim to fan
of snap will be coming back somehow in
Avengers 4 so the most obvious way that
dr. Pym could come back is that he comes
back with everybody else but I think if
it was just that then people wouldn't be
making such a big deal about it
including Sebastian Stan when Dave
Bautista leaked that the guardians were
coming back it wasn't really a big deal
he was just sort of like well yeah we're
coming back I thought everybody knew
that
so he could come back at the end of
Avengers 4 when the original Avengers
defeat Thanos and figure out a way to
bring everybody back but he also could
come back with everybody else that has
fallen victim to the snap before the
final battle in a Ben
four so in this interview they're
actually referring back to an old
interview that happened a while ago with
sebastian stan where he said that he was
doing a scene with michelle pfeiffer and
michael douglas so he dropped his
spoiler quite a while ago but he also
dropped the fact that everybody's gonna
be coming back this is what he had to
say in the interview where he spoiled it
for everybody there was one scene I
think we had where everybody was there I
can't really talk about that scene but I
knew it took of them three months and
planning the scene to have everybody
there you look around and you just saw
everyone from samuel l.jackson to
michael douglas to michelle pfeiffer
everybody was there so he actually
spoiled the fact that there's going to
be this huge scene in a vendor sport
where everybody is together maybe it
takes all of the heroes over the past
ten years that we've seen in the MCU
coming together as a team as a family
and perhaps that's what it takes to take
on Thanos and finally defeat him all the
Avengers United as one or as Charlie out
emergency awesome said this could
actually be Tony Stark and Pepper Potts
his wedding it would have all of our
heroes together to see Tony and pepper
get married and it would be a relatively
easy scene to shoot because there isn't
really any action it would be mostly
people sitting down and it's a great way
to end this first ten years and a great
way to see off Iron Man but another
option that I think is very likely to
happen is that ant-man will travel in
the past and he'll find dr. Pym in that
current time and dr. Pym will end up
helping him with quantum technology and
time travel we know that right now
currently ant-man is stuck in the
quantum realm and he'll most likely go
through one of the time vortexes to get
himself out so since it's a time vortex
there's really no way of telling where
he's going to end up but we know that
ant-man is going to introduce this time
travel technology to Tony Stark and
Bruce Banner but the thing is Scott Lang
isn't really too well-versed with
quantum technology he's going to need
some help if he's going to have to
explain it to Tony Stark
so perhaps this time vortex shoots
ant-man back in time he finds dr. Pym
and dr. Pym helps him get back to his
current time because ant-man isn't aware
of the snap right now so there are a
number of ways that doctor Hank Pym can
make his way back into the scene in
Avengers for what all of these leaks
really tell us is that the heroes that
fell victim to the snap aren't really
they're going to come back somehow but I
do think that time travel is going to be
a big part of how they come back and I
think that dr. Pym is going to play a
huge role with that whether it's a past
dr. Pym dr. Pym inside of the quantum
realm or dr. Pym inside of the soul
world he's gonna play a vital role to
the quantum realm and time travel so
that's it for the big spoiler that
everybody is talking about right now as
you can see there are many different
ways that dr. Pym and the rest of the
Fallen Heroes could come back and
Avengers 4 but what do you all think is
the most likely way that dr. Pym and the
rest of the Avengers will come back and
Avengers 4 let me know your thoughts in
the comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date with everything related to
Avengers 4 thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]